yeah hello and welcome to this video my
way is the opponent so yeah we had a
couple of those I still don't remember
what he plays some g6 business don't
quite remember with something with this
I shall I don't know let's see I'd f6
now is usually played know
yeah your wife has a little bit more
space in the center so should be a
little bit better for him but for white
I mean but it's nothing nothing out of
the ordinary so what does he do cannot
take on c3 so night we're 95 I will take
that looks pretty awful and it also
looks awful 52 maybe two thomas III just
threaten before winning the piece yeah
so before night v7 bag I don't know it
looks quite tempting but I can always
basically do it yeah I don't have to do
it straight away so which is super
strengthening moves now before yeah my
first complete development
you have to take and now all of a sudden
is a-ticking see form I assume it takes
with the bishop
maybe he takes with a pawn I mean
doesn't look like something you can
review tao tried you look somewhat wrong
but maybe you cannot just cannot punish
it immediately yeah i just develop
simple development queen d7 95 was my
idea on now 95 or make sense triumphal
Knight f6 you'll probably play pawn to
have six himself I mean does he just
play at six now precisely here I don't
know it looks very weakening to school
be sure that form came in 295 annoying
so 9 s6 fields you just moves the king
okay okay then push over 6 will be too
excited I cannot take the five and after
C takes the sea phallus is a disaster
okay so here
near
some are all that still still is a
position
thank you for I don't know maybe he has
to take my ideas f4 push him back or
maybe night b5 actually am I never guess
any of his moves I really never had
almost check some chick first Jack ship
first and we should have three probably
[Music]
lots of things on that diagonal
[Music]
yeah just be sure if three is good
um okay and now g45 or probably take it
ng5 let's let Spacely
maybe taste you form takes 24 okay so
probably just put this back okay like
result that's why it was a bit a bit too
loose somehow yeah I don't don't really
I don't really think this okay i just
wanted to he said thanks for the game
and my reply just it was too late yeah
so I actually came just bring a tease
them and more on my god oh I can't just
win apiece that's okay so he has to go
to if I bore ya played this position and
this is just I can just take and play
before and it's over I just win the full
piece oh my god okay I didn't do it okay
I can always play before but I was never
sure and now to be honest you get c6
back I mean this is the square I mean we
white is always a bit better but
probably in comparison yeah i don't know
i did that looks looks really good
couldn't be too now 94 is a good movie
ever it cannot really take a asus also
opening this up and yeah I think yeah
and so probably more less over check
yeah that's impossible I could have
taken a 97 but i think that is also
fairly yes radical insane yawn that
opening line is a little bit
questionable anyway if you want to play
like this at some this is better so that
you can actually put d5 put something in
the center yeah okay guys thanks for
watching